[Music]  second to be careful when you want to  use emails to escalate things we all  know this feeling something bothers you  a little bit angry so let's write an  email put lots of people on CC and  complain so of course these are often  also political games and I don't want to  say that this is always the wrong thing  to do but just one tip of advice that  actually I picked up from a high school  teacher back in the day is that person  told me you know when you are angry when  you really just want to say something to  someone sleep over it for one night just  take a break sleep over it for one night  if the next day you still feel like that  that this is the right thing to do then  go for it but often the next day you see  things far different you feel different  about it and then you might even regret  having written such an email